hey this is presto Walker solve for the
area of the circle that is centered at
the origin and inscribed between the
bell curves with equations y equals e to
the power of negative x squared and y
equals negative e to the power of
negative x squared can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution let's first plot the curves we
have the positive bell curve y equals e
to the power of negative x squared and
then we have the negative bell curve
before I go over the correct approach
let me explain an invalid method because
if I don't mention this someone will
invariably leave a comment that they
found an easier solution method this
approach will be a necessary condition
but not a sufficient condition so this
approach involves thinking about the
geometry if the circle is just touching
the curves then you could then solve for
the circles radius for the point at
which it's tangent to the curves this
could be accomplished by setting the
slope of the radius equal to the
negative reciprocal of the slope or
derivative of the curve so what I'm
going to explain is this is a necessary
condition and one of the values here
will coincidentally get to the answer
but this is not a sufficient condition
for justifying the answer let me explain
why one problem is that you might have
the radius of the circle being
completely vertical this is because
there's a point on this curve where the
slope is zero so if you were to consider
the derivative of this curve you may be
overlooking the point at which the
derivative is zero
because the negative reciprocal would
have to be an infinite value to consider
the case where the radius is vertical so
one mistake is you might potentially be
overlooking this solution but even if
you were to manually check for this case
there would be another issue you would
not know whether this circle is wholly
contained between these bell curves and
it turns out this particular circle is
actually not bound by these bell curves
so it would not be totally inscribed
between these curves now if you were to
use this incorrect approach you would
actually find another solution which
does correspond to the correct answer
but this will be an insufficiently
justified answer because you might be
overlooking other cases and you would
still have to show why the circle is
completely inscribed between the curves
so this is not a valid approach to
solving this problem
how can we solve it let's think about it
geometrically if the radius of the
circle is too small then it'll be wholly
contained between the bell curves but it
won't be touching the curves at some
point if we expand the radius the circle
will be too large so we're looking for
the point at which the radius is just
the right value at this point the
circles radius is just large enough to
touch the bell curves any smaller radius
would not touch the bell curves and any
larger radius would not be inscribed
between the curves this point happens
when the radius is the minimal distance
from the origin to the bell curves at
this minimal value you can't have any
smaller radius and you also wouldn't
want any larger radius because then you
would be touching the bell curves at
more points and it would not be wholly
inscribed so let's use this approach
by symmetry we can solve for the
distance to the positive bell curve with
point x comma e to the power of negative
x squared so want to minimize the
distance from the origin to the positive
bell curve and we can use the distance
formula to get the following expression
but before we continue our calculations
before we take the derivative and solve
for when it's equal to zero there's
actually an easier way to solve this
problem since distance is a non negative
value we can more easily minimize the
distance squared this will be the
distance squared from the origin to the
positive bell curve which ends up being
the same function without that messy
square root which will complicate our
derivative and further calculations this
is a standard trick whenever we want to
minimize the distance so now let's
tackle this problem we want the minimum
value of x squared plus e to the power
of negative 2x squared we'll take the
derivative and set it equal to zero to
solve for the critical values we end up
with the following equation which we can
factor out 2x and now we want to solve
for when this equation is equal to zero
so we have two possibilities one is that
2x will be equal to zero which means X
is equal to zero in that case we can
check that the distance squared will be
1 is this the minimal value well let's
check if the other solution leads to a
smaller distance squared so we have 1
minus 2 times e to the power of negative
2x squared needs to be equal to 0 we can
solve this equation to get x squared is
equal to the natural log of square root
of 2 if we substitute this back into the
distance squared we end up getting the
distance squared is approximately 0.847
and that's a smaller value than 1 so in
fact this will be the minimal distance
squared and this will be the x value
that we want we want x squared equals
the
natural log of square root of two we
reject the solution of x equals zero so
now with this distance squared value we
can then find that the distance squared
will be exactly the natural log of the
square root of two plus one-half and
notice the distance squared from the
origin to the bell curves is also equal
to the radius squared R squared of the
circle because the distance is equal to
the radius so finally we want the area
of this circle that'll be pi times R
squared which will equal pi times the
distance squared so we have pi times the
quantity natural log is square root of 2
plus 1/2 and that's our answer
did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math you can
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
if you like this video you can support
me on patreon and you can check out my
books which are listed in the video
description you can also catch me on
social media either at my dear decisions
or at pressed Hall Locker depending on
the site